the Voyager mission has been exploring
our solar system for decades now nature
reveals some of its latest findings I
personally feel like it's the greatest
mission of exploration that was ever
launched it's been to so many planets
discovered so many things and now it's
still discovering things 30 years after
it was launched
Nature has just published six papers
about the giant bubble the Sun creates
around itself called the heliosphere
and five of those papers depend on data
from the Voyager 2 spacecraft that
spacecraft was launched in August of
1977 on the journey to the giant outer
planets Jupiter Saturn Uranus and
Neptune Neptune the outermost is 30
times as far from the Sun as the earth
and today Voyager 2 is over 80 times as
far from the Sun as the earth at the
very outer reaches of this giant bubble
and we are trying to reach outside of
that bubble into interstellar space and
both War 1 and Voyager 2 are on the
journey to be the first to reach
interstellar space nobody has been an
interstellar space and in our lifetime
there probably would not be another
mission that's going to go there so
forger it's a crossing to the final
frontier is very exciting for scientists
and probably for the public as well
without the sun life would not exist we
would not be here asking the questions
about it we count on the Sun for
everything we are and everything we know
as familiar to us here on the earth and
it is you know it's our star that's
determining our environment our
existence we're almost obliged as as
intellectual beings to ask the question
why is it there and how does it work
the Sun like all stars creates a bubble
round itself and it's that bubble that
the interaction from the wind from other
stars and our own Sun interact and we
are now in the outer layer that of that
bubble where that interaction takes
place so for the first time we're now
able to observe how our star interacts
with what came from other stars outside
the solar wind is a stream of particles
flowing away from the upper atmosphere
of the Sun it is expensive to allow this
chance this solvent expands against the
interstellar medium creates a cavity
that hose our solar system this cavity
is called a heliosphere
you can make a heliosphere in your
kitchen sink by just running the water
into the not write directly on the drain
but to the side of the drain and as the
water comes down it hits the bottom of
the pan and begins to rush out in all
directions pretty much equally but not
quite easily but it rushes straight out
and it pushes back the water that's in
the pan it makes a little circle on
almost a circle and the reason that you
can't just push forever and just clean
out the whole thing is because as it
rushes out it just decreases in pressure
and it can't push back all that water
and so there's a finite extent to it and
that's the same thing that's happening
in our heliosphere the solar wind is
rushing out pushing back on the ions and
the magnet field of the galaxy making a
little bubble in it and the other thing
about it is the edge of the circle is
very turbulent rough
the solar wind plasma and the
interstellar plasma are coming in and
colliding with one another basically and
they're producing this very complicated
boundary layer of the inner heliosheath
and the outer heliosheath and the
termination shock between them war g2
has five key instruments on it to
measure the environment in this huge
bubble that's around the Sun the key
measurement has to do with the wind
coming from the Sun the solar atmosphere
is evaporating and speeding away at a
million miles per hour creating this
giant bubble and one of our instruments
measures that wind we measure it every
day looking for an evidence that we have
reached the outer edge of the supersonic
solar wind these three instruments
measure the ions the ionized atoms which
fill the outer part of the heliosphere
but we also measure the magnetic field
which is carried out by that ionized
wind as well as the waves in that wind
called plasma waves the instrument which
measures the magnetic fields is actually
on a boom which projects out this way of
13 meters 43 feet to get it away from
the spacecraft itself which contaminates
the very weak field that we're trying to
measure and the other instrument has two
10 meter long antennas one of which is
here and that measures the low-frequency
waves in the wind which tells us
something important about the wind
itself we've been studying something
called the anomalous cosmic rays with
our instrument these anomalous cosmic
rays come from deep in our galaxy and
have no electrical charge somehow at the
heliosphere termination shock
they've been accelerated to a high
energy but Alan Cummings found
surprising data from both voyagers there
would be more particles at low energy
and fewer at high energy and it'd be a
certain way that should look and that
didn't happen and we were really
astounded didn't happen in Voyager 1 and
so some theories were put forward well
maybe there was a transient from the Sun
just at the right time that caused those
particles to kind of be disrupted in
their acceleration we didn't see him if
it'd been a quiet period we would have
seen what we expected to see so we said
okay well have another chance with
Voyager 2
so would your to went through the Chuck
same thing we didn't see what we
expected to see at all
and so they origin the source where
these particles are accelerated is a big
mystery and what is the big one of the
big mysteries of the termination shock
crossings one of the interesting
surprises from the Voyager solar wind
instrument was that we expected all of
that energy from the million
mile-per-hour wind
when the roughly stopped or slowed down
to heat the wind itself to a million
degrees what we found instead that wind
was only a hundred thousand degrees
after it had slowed down
most of the energy 80% of the energy
went somewhere else meanwhile closer to
the earth
a pair of satellites called stereo were
launched to find out just how the sun's
influence affects our planet it was not
thoughts in any shape or form that it
would make a contribution to the
understanding of the boundary between
the solar wind and the interstellar
medium which was so distant from stereo
sorbets
but stereo had very capable instruments
and when you design a capable instrument
you're not quite sure exactly what
you're going to get when you finally get
into space
space is full of stuff the berkeley team
was surprised when stereos stee
instrument designed to measure low
energy electrons seemed to be receiving
another kind of signal
it was obviously detecting something
else that was out in space it could have
been the spacecraft background it could
have been some detector flaw or fault
but graduate student Ling Hwa with a bit
of sleuthing scientific sleuthing was
able to draw out the fact that this in
fact was a signal from the termination
shock at great distances from the stereo
spacecraft and we were in fact detecting
some particles that were very
complimentary to the Voyager
measurements in the sense that they were
giving information the voyager itself
could not achieve right at the site of
the termination shock it's really quite
remarkable that this spacecraft which
was launched when the space age itself
was only twenty years old has now been
operating for over thirty years only
journey to interstellar space we are now
exploring new areas that have never been
explored before and will not be explored
for many many years i'm generations
probably by the time the voyagers run
out of power in in 2020
we should have crossed into interstellar
space with at least one spacecraft and
we should be about 15 billion miles from
Earth they all will be constantly
watching what Voyager is seeing around
the next bend so for example when the
Sun becomes active again in the next
solar maximum a few years from now
they'll be coronal mass ejections
heading outward and colliding with the
termination shock probably causing
disturbances too it changes the shape
it's expected to be a very dynamic
boundary and so we may in fact pass in
and out of it several times even before
Voyager is it's truly in in an
interstellar space that's unadulterated
by anything the Sun has to throw out
well I think all of us feel we've been
very fortunate to have been on a journey
of discovery even if it had stopped in
1989 with Neptune we would have had an
immensely valuable mission but for it to
continue now for decades and be the
first to reach interstellar space I
think it's just an incredible journey of
discovery and we're all very fortunate
to been part of it